should accept yourself just the way you
are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
so that's why you're noticing
polarization go up everywhere not just
on the Israeli side of the debate on the
terrorism so everywhere there's
polarization because that's their method
for Change and so we've got to be
careful we're not being useful patsies
for dialectical materialism by using
language that continues The Divide
increases the Divide rather than bring
people together people are possessed to
a greater or lesser degree by this web
of ideas they reflect that in their own
perception and action
as individuals but then when they get
together as groups like imagine that a
given person is 25 possessed by the
politically correct web of ideas
but then you get a hundred people like
that in a room let's say at Davos and
then you have the whole web of ideas and
it has an animating ethos like it's it
looks at the world in a certain way and
is aiming at certain ends and then that
entire system of ideas
Works to promote that and it also means
that it can operate in a distributed
manner because to the degree that any
given person is possessed by some
fraction of those ideas they'll go off
into their own domain and agitate on
behalf of the idea system and that's a
principality and that will act to
further the entire uh the entire
catastrophe and really the the entire
idea system in its most fundamental
element is a it's an idol it's a false
idol it's a false religion
okay
[Music]
hello everyone I'm here today talking to
Majid Nawaz uh colleague and well
Dawning friend of mine we've spoken a
number of times in a variety of
different circumstances most recently
Majid had contacted me uh with some
opposition to things I had said or
allowed to be said
or facilitated the transmission of let's
say talking to Benjamin not Netanyahu
about the situation in Palestine and so
we've been going back and forth on that
front and decided to have a conversation
and so that's what's happening today
here and also on the daily wire on
YouTube and also on the daily wire plus
platform Majid Nawaz is a British
anti-extremist political commentator
activist and podcast host
he was recently released from his LBC
Radio Show as a consequence of his views
on the covid-19 pandemic he wasn't
really in favor of the mandated vaccines
and has been has has roots as one of the
original named members of the
hypothetical intellectual dark web along
with characters such as myself Douglas
Murray and Ben Shapiro
among others good to have a chance to
talk to Majid again today
chance to talk I don't I think I think
the last time we spoke I think was
probably on your show wasn't it and that
was what is that four years ago three
years ago
thank you for remembering I uh was very
proud to be the first national
broadcaster to conduct a long-form uh
interview with you in Britain on the
national Airwaves
um a job I was since canceled from but
it was around the time of your own
incredibly interesting uh conversation
on channel four when what became a meme
of course from there if you remember was
so what you're saying is and your
responses to the assistant question uh
basically were the stuff of Legends so
uh it's a pleasure being here again with
you Jordan and as I said thank you for
remembering uh that we had that
conversation they had some sound issues
oh yeah it's still on YouTube and uh
people can still catch that it was um uh
uh before the world went mad I think
even though we could probably both see
it was on the way to going mad
it was definitely on the way yeah that
uh that channel 4 interview with Kathy
Newman I think has 30 million views now
still doesn't it refuses to die but
interesting you know
um I was interviewed a couple probably
two years later by Helen Lewis for the
GQ on putatively for their issue on
masculinity strangely enough and uh that
interview
Helen had more tricks in her bag than
Kathy Newman in that interview now has
60 million views and so but they're
they're they're both reflections of the
same underlying
surreal strangeness that we see
ourselves constantly surrounded with now
yeah so but that's not where I first met
you though I first met you when uh I had
just finished my touring with Sam Harris
and uh you had just come on the scene
there with Sam and began your dialogues
right I was uh in the audience actually
for some of those especially the ones in
London
um and again thank you for having us at
your recent London event
Congressman that you met we were very
happy to see you there as well
we we met I think with Douglas Murray
didn't we at that point for uh for a
dinner dinner lunch yep yeah Tammy was
there Tammy was there Douglas was there
you were there and uh I think it was in
his London flat the time that he had and
we had a lovely conversation then as
well um yeah it's been a while it's been
many years we've been in touch but this
is I think the first time we've sat down
on your show
um and yeah it's actually I'm I'm very
happy that we're doing this because I
think the time is it's a good time yeah
so so for everybody watching and
listening I've been corresponding with
Majid for the last couple of months
trying to set this up and a fair bit of
that has circulated around the Abraham
Accord issue that I've been speaking
about and the israel-palestine situation
and so I thought we might as well hash
that out to begin with and so I'm not
exactly sure how to begin that I maybe
I'll start by talking about my
experience on the Abraham Accord front
and you can tell me you know what what
you think about that and then we'll dive
into the weeds so sure I I was very ill
for a good while
um from 2000 and even 2018 when I was on
tour but it got really bad by 2021 I was
kind of out of commission for about
three years and when I started to spring
back to life
some people in my circle alerted me to
the emerging fact of the Abraham Accords
and I started to keep an eye on them and
was very struck by what was happening
the fact that this peace process
putative peace process was emerging
outside of the confines of the state
department under the tender auspices of
Donald Trump and his organization and
it looked to me like an extraordinarily
it had the potential to be an
extraordinarily significant advance and
then I was struck by how much it was
downplayed in the let's say Legacy press
and also by the Democrats that I was
working with because I worked with some
Democrats behind the scenes for a very
long time and
was unable to elicit from them any real
enthusiasm for this move forward which
struck me as very very odd to say the
least and still does and since then I've
investigated the process by which the
Abraham Accords were
were negotiated with a number of the
people who were directly involved
including the former Israel ambassador
to the U.S and the American ambassador
to Israel and
um still am of the opinion that this
looks like
um Avenue to something approximating
peace in an area that has been
characterized by very little piece for a
very long time so in any case that's the
situation on my front and
we've exchanged a bit of email about
that topic and I'm well I'm very
interested in your views about the
abrahamic court and about to the degree
that you regard that as relevant about
my involvement with publicizing it
well first of all it's something I
raised as well before I was canceled on
my previous show
um on LBC I was canceled for the record
three months before my contract was due
to expire and the reason I was canceled
uh was very evident and clear to me I
have all the receipts and uh in fact
five years remaining on a legal case
that I initiated and the lawyers were so
happy with the case that they're doing
it uh without charge and uh my basic
point was that I was canceled for
raising covid mandates uh being what I
believe one of the greatest crimes ever
committed or attempted to be committed
Against Humanity and I objected to the
mandates and refused as a conscientious
objector to take uh from the booster
shot onwards having been coercively
injected in prison against my will I
thought that
um it was uh absolutely unacceptable for
the state to put me back in that
position yeah because everything I had
been everything I had been fighting for
since the up until that point including
I'll be saying this relates to the
Abraham Accords question you've just
asked me Jordan uh was for Universal
peace and love
and uh uh with the background that I
have which I won't go into now it's well
known and if anyone wants to catch up on
that they can watch my uh other
interviews but uh with the background I
I have I thought it was particularly
important for me to reach out to all
communities in peace and extend a hand
uh of Peace we say salaam alaikum when
we meet people and I did so with uh you
know I don't need to go over that as
well the track record there for the last
decade what I've been doing is very
clear it culminated in my dialogue with
Sam Harris Islam and the future of
Tolerance and that turned into a film so
when the Abraham Accords came about in
that Spirit Jordan
um of course you'd expect me uh to want
to give peace a chance and and my My
Views in reaction to that are on the
record they're all there online and
again before my job was canceled in fact
Clips were uploaded of me embracing uh
the opportunity for peace what I'd like
to say in response to your uh question
but it was I think it was necessary that
Preamble was necessary because I think
peace and uh though it must be embraced
it has to be regardless of power
dynamics I believe it has to be uh it
has to be presented the opportunity has
to be presented uh as if we are speaking
to equals and I don't mean equals in
terms of physical strength uh War
capabilities I mean uh human equals I
mean cognitive equals I mean spiritual
uh equals and for that reason uh uh I'm
probably again a caveat for what I'm
about to say I'm probably one of the
most vocal Muslim voices in the west who
has advocated for giving peace a chance
considering my background and where I've
come from I have every excuse uh not to
want to give peace a chance when it
comes to how the world has treated
certain people including me in the past
but I think it's really important that
we have to uh fight for peace and why
one of the ways that it's possible is
regardless of material power dynamics we
approach the so-called adversary who's
really a mirror of ourselves as an equal
and the reason I mention that is that
there's certain language around the
entire question of the Middle East and
it's what I I think I gave you a bit of
a telegraph I'm sorry Jordan
um it's better in person with a smile
than it is um online so I'm happy to
have this opportunity to explain why I
believe this is a a much better way for
us to uh to progress and that is because
there are certain language that is used
around
not just the Abraham Accords but peace
in the Middle East which can be
unintentionally can come with uh with
stigmatizing connotations
that build up a feeling of otherness as
opposed to Bringing people closer
together which is a prerequisite for
peace our language has to bring people
closer together if our language is
stigmatizing while we're saying that we
want peace then unfortunately that's not
the behavior of somebody that wants
peace that's the behavior of somebody
who wants to blame the adversary for
still being angry while they've extended
a hand of peace and the only persons
that have the ability to do that are
those that have the material power in
other words the luxury to be able to
afford uh speaking uh in tones that are
divisive while saying I'm extending a
hand In Peace So a person that has
nothing but their dignity to try and
defend in any War situation uh will only
ever expect people to address them as a
cognitive and a spiritual equal on a
human level
so when I say language you're no
stranger to this Jordan because of your
own
um uh your own expertise and what in
fact has led you to prominence around
the world because you understand the
importance of language and context and
symbolism and tradition
so
um we're gonna I would love to revisit
this question language actually
um as we continue speaking later on but
for now I'll just say the example uh
because I think it goes all the way back
to
um the oral tradition and why
um it's important to remember uh before
the written word uh how language was
received and given um which I'm sure
you're aware to what I'm eluding in
terms of the Semitic tradition as well
but uh we can come to that later for the
moment what I'd like to say is write
down to if we won't be Abraham Accords
to work uh write down to uh the the
adjectives we use to describe it
um as I said I've probably done with
respect and I don't mean this to be in
any sense arrogant uh Jordan I don't
mean to boast and I don't mean to put
you down I've probably done more than
you on uh for peace in the Middle East
um I that wouldn't surprise me at the
least
and I've suffered for it
um and so take this from my brother who
says it to you uh that I think that for
example when we say things like
judeo-christian Civilization
when we know for a fact that
historically
um all of the uh the philosophies and
the principles that we cherish so dearly
in our small own a small s open
societies because I don't want to
endorse soros's program of open Society
so all of the principles and values we
endorse in are smaller and smallest open
societies
um were protected cherished and then
translated by the golden era in the
Middle East during the time of the
ancient caliphates uh and we know the uh
the heritage of Andalucia Islamic Spain
and the way in which the philosophies
were preserved from there how may
monenders and others emerge from there
and we understand therefore that uh part
of this equation Judo Christian
civilization uh it's a deliberate uh uh
it's a deliberate amputation of a limb
not to uh not to include Muslims within
that conversation and so abrahamic is
more inclusive but I've noticed uh
people increasingly use judeo-christian
civilization when talking about
challenging the world for example
another problem there is that why what
does that lead to why am I raising that
because the the other ring words for me
I believe are are spells
and when we cast spells we create
feelings in people that Reserve that
receive those words so when we speak in
those terms that excludes one key
element of that uh from that
conversation though of course I know I'm
a British Citizen and I'm welcome here
in uh in this discourse
um if I if it's a judeo-christian
civilization I'm expected to assimilate
into then I will always be the other and
I will always be approaching this
discourse uh from an outside perspective
and will be heard as the other by those
on the inside but if we understand that
our civilization isn't only
judeo-christian and in fact uh right
down to algebra coming from
al-jabbarismi who invented the concept
uh the the siffer or the zero either
coming from the Sanskrit in Indian or
from the Arabic uh numerals
um you know I could go on and on if we
understand that then there's no way uh
that that
philosophically we could ever find
ourselves in a position where whether
with thought or not we don't raise
there's no way we could ever raise a
question
that erases the existence of a people
and that's what I believe happened when
you spoke to Netanyahu I believe the
attempt to erase the existence of
Palestinians I believe the attempt to
present the squatter analogy uh in other
words as was expressly stated in that
conversation between you and not uh uh
Benjamin Netanyahu that this was empty
land had no occupies and therefore when
we arrived like the squatters in an
empty property we immediately have right
over this land and and that recognizes
absolutely no claim
for Palestinians I believe that's
exclusionary language and doesn't Aid
the spirit of What's called the Abraham
Accords okay recognize a people say
Jordan uh yeah please yeah no no go
ahead it's not a new point it's not a
new Point uh um so when we when we do
that of course how do we expect
Palestinians to receive that language
if they receive it being excluded that
leads to reaction in other words anger
it leads to a separation not a bringing
together and I acknowledge one thing by
the way that the term Palestinian in our
language is a modernist term so I'm not
getting stuck on semantics I'm saying
that there were an Arab people there as
well and they must be acknowledged
whether you want to call them
Palestinians whether you want to call
them shami Yin Leven sign today they
happen to be in the area that is within
Israeli military Authority called the
West Bank today they happen to say okay
you know this is we're Palestinian
because this is the ancient land of
Palestine I don't prefer I prefer not to
get stuck on semantics I know
netanyahu's argument is oh but there was
no such thing as Palestine there was no
such thing as Israel before 1948 there
was no such thing as Pakistan my parents
country origin of which I have a
national ID card I'm not dismissing or
lowering or belittling any country yeah
so we have to I think acknowledge
identity uh so that we can have the
conversation the spirit for which
Abraham Accords the spirit for which it
was named I hope that makes sense
hey Reagan I know you're picky when it
comes to skin care products so tell me
what did you think of genucel skin care
exactly right Garrett I'm the type of
person who needs to know exactly what
ingredients I'm using in my skincare
routine which is why I'm loving genucel
their products are made with
antioxidants and formulated by a
compounding pharmacist and they're all
about preventative skin care I've been
using genucel's new microbiome
moisturizer to Target skin redness fine
lines and other signs of premature aging
it uses the same probiotics that are in
your yogurt as it turns out these super
ingredients can have the same nourishing
benefits on your skin as they do to your
digestive system the results have been
incredible my skin cleared up within
hours
genu cell has a product for every skin
type and it's not just for us girls I
got started with their most popular
package which includes all their best
sellers bundled into one amazing price
you heard it here first go to
genucel.com Jordan to get 70 off their
most popular package that's genucel.com
Jordan genucel.com Jordan
okay so you you brought up three very
complex issues there and so let me walk
through them one by one
so
one of the things that has struck me
very positively
in my life in the last five years is the
fact that
the work that I've done particularly
with regards to the elucidation of the
meaning of Genesis has attracted a very
large number of Muslims
and I'm very happy about that and I've
had completed a number of podcasts with
Muslim thinkers I would say across the
entire
spectrum of Muslim thought not
comprehensively obviously but people
ranging from pretty traditionalist I
would say Muslim fundamentalists to
people who are as liberal on the Muslim
side as it gets and then also critics of
the Muslim tradition like Ayan Hersey
Ali
trying to you know understand more
deeply
the situation that we find ourselves in
and I need to say a couple of things I
mean I'm extraordinarily ignorant in
relationship to my understanding of
Islamic culture it's it's it's a closed
book to me in many ways I've I've done
what I could to rectify that but it's
very difficult to come to an
understanding of your own culture much
less to try to claim expertise in the
niceties of someone else's culture
especially when it's an extraordinarily
diverse culture so you know I'm
stumbling around in a sea of ignorance
and I would also say the same thing with
regards to the situation in Jerusalem I
mean I was just in Jerusalem a couple of
months ago for the first time and one of
the things you learn very rapidly if
you're in Jerusalem for even a few days
is that that place is so bloody
complicated that it's no it's amazing
it's not on fire all the time
and so and and clearly it's also the
case that whenever there's ongoing
conflict like there is in the Middle
East it's because the situation is so
complex
that no one and everyone has a handle on
it no one understands and that's why it
descends into Warfare there's no
agreement on what the realities are and
so people fight and so the problem with
commenting on that or putting a toe in
the water is that the probability that
you're going to say something stupid and
the certainty that you're going to eat
by piranhas approaches a hundred percent
so
well so so now having said that I would
also say that I'm very
sympathetic to your notion that
the there's something very important to
accomplish here in the next 10 or 15
years on the abrahamic side
no so you said that the notion of
judeo-christian culture is exclusionary
and then you outlined a variety of
problems with that and
that that's an extraordinarily
complicated problem because I do believe
that there are affinities between
Christians and Jews and Muslims that are
very very deep and they're ex
particularly important right now because
Muslims Jews and Christians have more in
common
than any of the members of those three
groups have in common with this woke
ideology that's pervasively sweeping the
planet that poses an equal threat to all
three of those groups and whatever
civilization might be founded on their
joint and separate contributions and the
fact that Muslims Jews and Christians
are squabbling amongst themselves in the
rubble while the idiot woke ideology
rages madly out of control is is is uh
counterproductive to say the least and
so you know on the religious front the
abrahamic religions share
the belief in the centrality of the book
they share a fundamental monotheism
um and then and then after that
well then differences that are difficult
to reconcile start to emerge and no one
really knows how to deal with them so I
mean obviously one of the problems on
the religious front with regards to Jews
Christians and Muslims is
conceptualization of the figure of
Christ and also of the figure of
Muhammad and no one knows how to sort
that mess out and what you get are
dogmatic insistences on both sides
um with the Jews taking a completely
different perspective and you know Wars
have been fought for hundreds of years
or even thousands over exactly those
issues so I do believe there are
important
uh historical
what would you say there's there's an
important history that unites us and
there's an important body of conceptions
that unites us on the religious side on
the on in the broad West but we're still
in the early stages of the kind of
conversation that would allow those
remaining
points of contention which are very
severe to be ironed out but but but
to your point
what that at least implies in part is
that language that is predicated on the
assumption that the central civilizing
tenancy in the west is only
judeo-christian
well you know that brings with it a host
of potential problems like the ones you
outlined and then you talked about the
the net and Yahoo conversation with
regards to the Palestinians and their
Erasure and that's extraordinarily
complicated as well and maybe I'll make
a case
for my viewpoint or the Viewpoint that I
tentatively hold at the moment and you
can tell me what you think about it sure
sure okay so clearly having the
Palestinians
drawn centrally into the process that's
unfolding on the Abraham Accord side is
desirable
now
let's see if we can figure out some of
the impediments to that I mean one
impediment for me is that it's very
convenient for actors outside of the
immediate Locale of Palestine and Israel
to ensure that the conflict rages
untrammeled for as long as possible and
it isn't obvious to me at all that the
Palestinians have been well served by
their own structures of governance
and I think that's partly because the
tradition of democratic governance is
not well founded in many places in the
Middle East and because as I said it's
very convenient for
bad external actors to ensure that the
conflict with Israel rages unabated and
and then
I I would say I'm also sympathetic to
the Israeli claim
for a variety of reasons
and let me lay those out and I don't
know how those can be pursued without
being
well also taking into account the fact
that this is unfortunately done not
infrequently at someone's expense
I mean the founder of
Zionism rightly observed that there was
a Dawning wave of vicious anti-Semitism
in Europe that was going to be
incredibly destructive and that was
definitely the case and then it was the
case that the West in the guise of the
U.N let's say decided
um that the establishment of a Jewish
state was going to be all things
considered something like uh a universal
good and it's definitely the case that
the establishment of that state has been
incredibly problematic but that one of
the consequences is that there's a
flourishing nation in that area now that
is doing quite well economically and on
the governance side and that has become
powerful enough economically and morally
I suppose but at least practically to be
regarded as a worthy Ally by the
countries that have signed the Abraham
Accords and
what that has meant is that the
Palestinian situation is still
unaddressed and the catastrophes that
are associated with that still playing
themselves out and it isn't obvious to
me
it isn't obvious to me at all what can
be done about that now your point was
well one thing that could be done is not
to exclude the Palestine Palestinians uh
linguistically or practically and I
would say fair enough but I don't I
don't know how we address the bad actor
problem which is partly the fact that
it's pretty damn convenient for people
who are anti-israel in the most
fundamental sense to keep the
Palestinian conflict raging
for their own particular narrow
self-interest and that's a true
impediment to peace it was also a true
impediment to peace that the bloody
state department has insisted for the
last 70 years that there's no
possibility whatsoever of moving even
incrementally towards peace in the
Middle East without a full solution to
the Palestinian problem which the people
who established the abrahamic corps
demonstrated in a very short period of
time was a Preposterous claim so okay so
let's let's go from there I would much
rather see the Muslims and the Jews and
the Christians uh what would you say arm
and armed together on the monotheistic
front that'd be nice but how the hell we
do that that's yeah well listen
um you mentioned you entered this debate
from the Abraham Accords onwards um so
forgive me if I assume that but that's
what I gathered if it's wrong
um I I can assure you I've been living
this debate for my entire life I I
um have been to Jerusalem and the West
Bank so I'm online to uh uh a ten of
even up and down the country to the
Golden Heights and down into the South
uh I've been on the Egyptian side uh of
the Border uh with Raza I I uh have been
right into uh the various sites there
I've prayed there in the Masjid Al-Aqsa
and the competition and one thing I can
assure you with the last decade of my
work on this front is um I'm not really
interested in the last thing you
mentioned there which is presenting
obstacles to peace and so I'm with you
on that I think I think there are vested
interests that want the conflict to
continue the question is Jordan uh that
it be overly simplistic to assume that
those vested interests are only on one
side of the debate okay fair enough yeah
I come at this as somebody who uh again
it's all open you can look it up I have
uh gone further than uh
almost any Muslim you will find in the
English language on this conversation
and I refuse to go any further because
I find the people purporting themselves
to be partners speaking the language of
alienation demonization apnea and
exclusion so let's agree on one thing if
it holds as you said that there is more
in common than there's different which I
believe is self-evident
uh then that and and it then holds by
definition that if we were to be able to
somehow rally around the fact that we
have more in common than what's
different
and I think that's also self-evident
that we'd have then uh we would achieve
a great price for peace on planet Earth
if we were able to do that so by
definition I don't need an answer to the
question how can we do that to say to
you with the full confidence of somebody
whose heart is where your heart is that
the way to do that isn't to use
exclusionary language
and I think that needs to be the
starting point because you know and I
know how it feels to be excluded you've
been canceled your voice has been taken
by people that have wanted to silence
you and this Muslim who's been to prison
for a belief in Islam that I now no
longer subscribe to but we're all
products to a certain extent of our
environment and experiences
I was one of the first national
broadcasters in Britain to reach out to
you and say your voice was taken away uh
my belief in infinite love demands that
your voice is now heard on a point of
principle
regardless of whether I agree with you
or not
now that's the philosophy I approached
this conversation with which is why
when anti-Semitism was rising in this
country again you will find that my
voice was the one despite how difficult
it was considering my background that
was the voice in Britain that was raised
probably among the loudest to say I have
a covenant with my Jewish cousins that
as far as we're concerned they must feel
that their rights are life and property
and family and all of that is kept
sacred
and so the point I'm making is that if
it holds as I believe it doesn't you've
stated it yourself that we have more in
common than is different
and if our only problem is how do we
arrive at a common basis for that
sharing of what we have in common and
celebrating it then it's a no-brainer
that the language we're using in the
meanwhile while we're trying to work out
how to arrive there will be language
that brings people closer not pushes
people further apart and that would be
what I'd say to Kanye West by the way is
what actually I have said to people that
speak like Kanye West who have started
encouraging me to speak like that but
likewise I'd expect people like
Netanyahu to abide by the very thing
that he says he fears arising from other
people and that is people denying his
identity his country's identity and
their own trauma in their own history I
have visited Yad vashem
I have been many times with my bro my
brethren in the Jewish Community it's a
holocaust museums and I have cried
because it's human suffering just like I
cry in the mosque when I'm asking Allah
to elevate suffering in turkey and Syria
right now with the thousands and
thousands who have died in the
earthquake it's human suffering and so
if that if it holds that that's the
intention that we have our language will
not divide it will only try and bring
people closer together I can't sit here
and claim to you I have the answer to
peace in the Middle East that would also
be incredibly arrogant what I can say to
you is that that answer whenever and
however it's arrived at one day I
believe it will be arrived at because
you know at the end of the day we don't
want to start engaging in
self-fulfilling prophecies uh if we
believe peace is never possible we will
be in Perpetual War that's how language
Works we're casting spells so if I as I
am I believe that peace is possible
because I believe in The Human Condition
enough to sacrifice for that in terms of
my own uh background of where I'm coming
from and to have uh people attack me for
saying peace is possible uh then what I
expect is my interlocutor will adhere to
the same uh language that reflects their
intention I believe you're a smart man I
believe you're understanding what I'm
saying but I believe that there are
vested interests on both sides of this
war because there are people that
believe in the hegelian dialect they've
subscribed to dialectical materialism
what they want is conflict to create
change we know Klaus Schwab subscribes
to that he calls it build back better
after a great reset and the way that
they bring change is by encouraging
division this dialectical materialism
was created by materialists and they
understand that if they want to advance
their interests they need to pick groups
against each other the British Empire
did it in the name of divide and conquer
but actually it's theoretical
underpinning as you're aware of Jordan
is the hegelian dialect upon which was
built the Communist idea of dialectical
materialism and it's this belief that
only conflict advances Civilization now
that conflict can come in many forms at
this month's One World Government Summit
which was also happened to be I believe
hosted in one of the countries that
assist uh subscribed to the Abraham
Accords
um
uh the uh speakers Klaus Schwab and The
Usual Suspects told us that they believe
shocks to Planet uh Earth are what are
required to bring about the the great
reset that they are pursuing those
shocks that they're talking about
whether it's a cyber blackout whether
it's uh the covid Mandate period and the
shocks being depriving us of our civil
liberties uh those shocks in the form of
Net Zero carbon targets where they want
to uh enslave us within 15 minute Zone
cities as if we're surfs those shocks
are designed to bring about conflict and
riots so that they can create change
through this dialectical materialism now
there's people that subscribe to that uh
methodology on the Israeli side of the
debate which is hence Pfizer being a
major culprit with the Israeli
government uh in all of this the Israeli
government uh today it's just been
released some documents name the three
ingredients in those covid mandates but
there are also people of course on all
sides of the debate not just the Israeli
side uh in Canada where you're from just
today or yesterday Christia Friedland
the Freeland the Democrat the deputy pm
has announced the results of the
emergency uh yeah inquiry and stated
that they were right to cut everyone's
money off Jordan they're not yeah
they're not stupid people they know this
angers people they know there's a risk
of riots they know there's a risk of
terrorism but that's why they're doing
it because if you can if you can bring
about the conditions in which people
can't eat because they can't buy food
and and and as was published in the
Times newspaper of London today they're
now suggesting rationing rationing in
Britain to bring about the carbon uh
targets the agenda yeah that doesn't
surprise me in the least I I watched
yesterday someone at the WF talk about
demand Management on the power that's
right Vision side so there are bloody
excuses well we can't provide you with
reliable power anymore so we want
centralized control over your appliances
so we can shut down your use of energy
when it becomes inconvenient for the
system
now we've got to understand why they're
doing this Jordan though they're doing
it so that the conflicts increases on
both side that's why you're noticing
polarization go up everywhere not just
on the Israeli side of the debate on the
terrorism so everywhere there's
polarization because that's their method
for Change and so we've got to be
careful we're not being useful patsies
for dialectical materialism by using
language that continues The Divide
increases the Divide rather than bring
people together
okay so the first thing I would say
about all that is that I just re-watched
Eisenhower's speech on the military
industrial complexes 1961 speech with my
wife this week because I was curious
once again what had motivated someone
who was so well versed in the
machinations of the behind the scenes
military industrial Enterprise to put
forward that warning 60 years ago and it
certainly uh the case that that
situation hasn't improved and it's it is
definitely the case that as you point
out there are vested interests
um promoting conflict everywhere on both
sides of every conflict I mean we're
certainly seeing that play out on the
Russia Ukraine front at the moment in
that this is
okay well okay well okay now I think
it's the wrong question magic and here's
why I think that so well there's this
idea that is deeply rooted in in um in
the CR in Christian traditional thought
of the idea of principalities
and a principality I'm going to think
about it psychologically instead of
religiously sure so what we're in now at
the moment is a war of of idea Networks
and an idea network has an animating
Essence so you you you see that
reflected in the use of terms such as
Zeitgeist you know the spirit of the
times and you see that
the animating
uh nature of a set of ideas when you
look at photographs from different
decades you see how Styles move and
shift everybody across the decades and
that becomes very evident As you move
away from the decades I mean people in
the 60s didn't think they looked like
people in the 60s but you could sure
tell now that they did
and that's partly because we're all
imitating each other all the time and
we're all striving for consensus and
we're all possessed by webs of ideas
that happen to be old Quran during the
time and place that we happen to be born
and we have a Rat's Nest of postmodern
slash neo-marxist ideas operating behind
the scenes at the moment that is rooted
in it's rooted in a corrupt
Enlightenment and it's it's rooted
beyond that in a an envious uh spirit of
cain-like vengefulness that's ancient
and that system of ideas tends to act
like a conspiracy and so imagine that
there's a so with one of my graduate
students just before I got canceled as a
professor
we undertook a uh formal statistical
evaluation of the universe of
politically correct ideas
okay so here were the questions we were
trying to answer the first question was
was there a coherent set of ideas that
could be identified as politically
correct and the way you assess that is
you gather a tremendous number of
questions about political opinion as
diverse arranges you can manage gather
them everywhere and then you give those
to thousands of thousands of people and
find out their opinions
and then you conduct a statistical
analysis and you see if people answer
question a in a particular direction
what other questions are they likely to
answer in the same direction and
are there correlations
between those are there does that
constitute a correlation pattern across
many many people so the question is what
ideas hang together as a set
and we found there were two domains of
ideas that hung together as sets on the
clearly politically correct side and one
was a kind of inclusive
compassionate liberalism and the other
was something more like an authoritarian
uh political correctness so imagine you
took the liberal compassion inclusive
domain of ideas and you Allied that with
willingness to use compulsion and force
okay so those that set of ideas clearly
two of them hung together and that those
two sets were correlated so the notion
that there is a web of ideas that are
part of this dialectical materialism
that you described or that would be a
subset of it that's clearly the case now
we also looked at what predicted that so
let's say there is that system of ideas
who's most likely to be possessed by it
and the answer was
well the first the biggest predictor was
low verbal intelligence
and it's partly because at the core of
that idea is set is a very simple
proposition which is that you can
understand all of Human Social and
psychological Dynamics merely by
referring to the principle of power and
oppression
and so it's a radical simplification and
that turns out to be attractive to
people who aren't very verbally
sophisticated okay the next predictor
was being female the next predictors
were having a feminine temperament and
the final major predictor was having
ever taken a course that was overtly
propagandistic on the politically
correct side
and so well that was all very worrisome
as you might as you might imagine but
but here's the reason I'm telling you
all this is that
we're seeing a situation where it looks
like there are conspiracies at work and
sometimes there are but what's actually
happening is that people are possessed
to a greater or lesser degree by this
web of ideas they reflect that in their
own perception and action
as individuals but then when they get
together as groups like imagine that a
given person is 25 possessed by the
politically correct web of ideas
but then you get a hundred people like
that in a room let's say a Davos and
then you have the whole web of ideas and
it has an animating ethos like it's it's
looks at the world in a certain way and
is aiming at certain ends and then that
entire system of ideas
Works to promote that and it can do that
and writes books promoting it and writes
about promoting it yeah speech is
promoting it yeah absolutely well and
and it also means that it can operate in
a distributed manner because to the
degree that any given person is
possessed by some fraction of those
ideas they'll go off into their own
domain and agitate on behalf of the idea
system and that's a principality and
that will act to further the entire uh
the entire catastrophe and really the
the entire idea system in its most
fundamental element is a it's an idol
it's a false idol it's a false religion
so uh can I say I agree with everything
you've just described I think it's a
beautiful way of describing uh what I
was alluding to I don't think there's
one Mastermind stroking a cat uh sitting
behind a bit like Danger Mouse uh which
was a very famous British cartoon that I
used to watch as a child and it had this
character called Baron Greenback and he
used to stroke the white cat and laugh
and cackle as Danger Mouse and penfold
his sidekick
bespectical sidekick called penfold uh
who bless him happen to be quite short
and boarding uh with this with
spectacles I think the whole point was
that they want to outshine Danger Mouse
in and danger Mouse's presence but I
don't think there's some Baron Greenback
figure stroking a cat because I've met
uh enough of the of the front line
candidates for those who fancy
themselves as Baron green back figures
and I don't respect their abilities to
pull off such a feat uh having looked at
them in the eyes right well that's the
other well exactly well yes exactly
that's the other problem so the
conspiratorial theories is that yeah so
I agree with your description of it
where I uh where I would perhaps push
you a bit to go a bit more into this
description perhaps upper layer if I may
Jordan is to say that it struck me
um as
as describing the reality from
one end of a dualist perspective
and I need to elaborate that I need to
unpack that to really explain what I
mean
um that happens what you describe the
reason people engaging in dialectical
materialism are seeking to do this uh uh
and and utilize or sorry weaponize
political ideas for the purposes of
bringing change uh to exploit conflict
uh for a direction of travel which is
what dialectical materialism essentially
boils down to the exploitation of
conflict for a direction of travel
um they would call that direction
Progressive
uh the reason they're doing that is
because they are they are very upset
with the status quo
and they believe that the status quo has
not even failed us uh but is actively
harming us
now the problem I have with what you
said isn't what you said again I
emphasize I agree with everything you
said I just believe you described half
the picture
the other half of the picture is
everything you said is also being done
by those to whom it's being done too
in other words those engaging in uh
woke political activism canceling
they're reacting to the way in which the
machine uh the state
has such a power hegemony over them that
it also by the way believes that the
ends justify the means let's not pretend
that when the state in Canada shut off
people's money that it doesn't believe
the ends justify the means
um and the problem here we've got is
that we've got people resisting to this
resisting the status quo posing it with
something just as absurd because what
the vision they want to get to uh
equality not Equity uh results in
tyranny
um but what they're what they're
opposing also has an element of the
Absurd in it because we saw some of that
with the unbridled corporatism uh that
is uh on display uh through the big
pharmaceutical companies and the way in
which they're prepared to kill human
beings for profit
now now the problem here that's why I
said it's what you've described in my
view is is a critique of half of the
problem
and if we can zoom out here and
understand that this whole thing is
caught in uh uh uh the entire thing's
caught in problem reaction solution
right and if we understand then that the
problem here isn't the proton uh or the
neutron but actually both of them
recognizing they're part of an atom you
know uh and if they understand they're
part of an atom if they understand
they're part of one whole
uh then perhaps they won't approach the
world's problems through a subject
object lens and other in through a
perspective of my grievance my pain my
victimization is valid and yours is
invalid uh because you're the one doing
it to me that subject object it's
separation
um and I believe that separation is at
the root cause of all of this if we
could understand that in fact we were
all uh in our own ways
um one part of an indivisible whole
the uh uh there is no single Center in a
sphere for example every point on a
sphere is its Center and yet it's still
a point right if we look at the world in
a different way I think that we could
escape this trap because the problem
I've got isn't just with the woke people
Jordan and I'm very happy with your work
on that front and I think that more so
than uh most other people I can think of
if not all other people I can think of
your interviews on that front have been
game changing and I I congratulate you
for that but my problem is a lot deeper
than that my problem is when I'm calling
the machine it demonstrated its power
now kovid mandates and the imposition
of mandatory injections against a
population uh and being told that we
would lose our jobs for example we would
uh we would remain locked in our homes
unless we consented that's not a woke
thing to do
um in the caricature of the sense of the
woke idea that we have in our heads that
put it to put it candidly for you that
is uh at the state flexing its muscles
and demonstrating that it can do what it
wants because it's been captured that
the second part is my analysis of it
because it's been captured by corporate
interests and in this case they are big
pharmaceutical corporate interests
so we've got uh um we I think we need to
understand that uh they're also engaging
in subject object they're also engaging
in uh other rising and I think that's
where the problem begins and therefore
of course the solution isn't political
the solution isn't in any way short term
this is a long term solution to heal
what I believe has become a global uh uh
problem of
uh human beings living in a state of
permanent psychosis or separation from
the Life Source
separation from being connected
uh infinite love
a a an externalization of the other and
that's happening across the board which
is why we're seeing polarization I can't
think of a time in my lifetime and I'm
younger than you I I I accept that I've
seen a polarization uh this severe
around the world
um and that's because everyone is the
victim
and everyone else is their oppressor
we'll be right back first we wanted to
give you a sneak peek at Jordan's new
series Exodus
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest
[Music]
beholden is presented precisely as that
spirit that allies itself with the cause
of Freedom against tyranny I want
villains to get punished but do you want
the villains to learn before they have
to pay the ultimate price that's such a
Christian question
all right so I would say the most
sophisticated metaphysical solution
to that problem of externalized
oppressor narrative is
it it's it's this it's the
spiritualization of that so let me walk
through that very carefully and you tell
me what what you think about it so
there's this idea it's very difficult to
know where to start this
so there's this idea that's laid out in
the story of Genesis in the story of
Adam and Eve that
um the garden that human beings inhabit
is permanently
uh co-inhabited by a serpent
and that serpent is the Eternal predator
of mankind you can look at it
biologically and you can look at it for
example as reflecting the fact that
mammals and reptiles have been in
Conflict for 60 million years and you
can look at it as a reflection of the
fact that snakes themselves have been
the enemies of us and our tree dwelling
ancestors since time immemorial and you
can look at it as a reflection of the
fact that human beings are subject to
the ravages of predation and that's
particularly true of infants and so
part of our mammalian Heritage as well
as our spiritual Heritage is the fact
that we can be prey animals and that we
always have to contend with that
now the question emerges from that and
this is a very deep metaphysical
question
what is the essence of what's predatory
and then what is the best response to
the fact of that essence
and so
what happens in the Corpus of Christian
thoughts surrounding the story of the
serpent in the Book of Genesis is that
the serpent there becomes assimilated to
the figure of Lucifer and Mephistopheles
to the figure of Satan
and and Satan this is Milton's take in
particular Satan is identified with the
serpent and now what that means is that
the image of Satan symbolically is put
forward as the most apt representative
of the predator
and so here here's how it might go
psychologically in terms of depth of
insight so you want to protect your
children from
actual natural predators and you could
throw snakes into that category and
wolves and just the the natural the
animals that would pose a predatory
danger but then that isn't the only
predator and it's not Predator as such
it's a specific Predator a snake or a
bear or a wolf it's not the concept of
predator or predation as such
and then you might think well
you need a more
Global and coherent representation of
predator and that's what a dragon is a
dragon is a meta Predator it's a it's a
cat it's a snake it's fire it's a
predatory bird it all entangled into one
image and that's the image of the
predator and the great mythological
stories of the hero confronting the
dragon is the human being taking a
stance against the Predator
but the greatest
Dragon isn't merely a dragon it's
something metaphysical and so what does
that mean well if you're a mother and
you're protecting children your children
from snakes and then from predators and
then from dragons you're also protecting
them against the evil in your own house
and the evil in your neighbor's heart
and The Evil Within the breast of your
own children
and that starts to become something
increasingly metaphysical and the the
final transmutation of that idea is that
the most profound battle against the
Predator is the battle that's undertaken
Within
so you say well we shouldn't other and
exclude we shouldn't other people and we
shouldn't exclude them we shouldn't look
for a convenient place to put Satan
that's
that's the danger that Renee Gerard has
pointed to with regards to the idea of
scapegoating is we want to offload the
moral burden onto those we regard as
essentially demonic in their motivation
we want to be on the side of the Good by
offloading that we want to do that
without doing any of the work and that's
part of the motivation for using
exclusionary language when the proper
attitude is to take on the apocalyptic
nightmare of separating the wheat from
the chaff inside our own spirits and to
clean ourselves so to speak so that
we're no longer unwitting
agents possessed by that predatory
spirit and that makes it into a
psychological process rather than
something we have to act out in the
world and my sense at the moment is that
we're all making that decision we're
either going to undertake this
looming transformation as a
psychological Enterprise or we're going
to play it out as fate in the world that
was Young's diagnosis by the way at the
end of the second World War
and so your attempts right now to engage
with me to say well let's not use
exclusionary language and dump all the
moral culpability onto someone else the
Palestinians for example because we're
just playing into the hands of those
that are engaging in this conspiratorial
possession I think that's all true it's
murky and it's difficult to to
straighten out but it's it's true and
one more thing and then all one more
thing on one of the points you made so
you talked about the use of fascist
collusion to further what looks like
something even more extensive than the
woke agenda I also agree with that and
this is where my thinking I would say
tilts more towards the classical left is
that the left has always been good at
pointing out the dangers of corporate
gigantism but what we're seeing now is
an emergence of gigantism that's not
merely corporate it's corporate
governmental and media all coming
together at the utmost levels of the
power hierarchy all devoted towards
something like the imposition of
stricture and the use of compulsion and
force to produce something like this
revolutionary change that you've been
alluding to mostly motivated at least
hypothetically by by you know the stated
desire to save the virginal planet from
being ravaged at the hands of the
industrial nightmare and so that's all
going on behind the scenes at the same
time
yeah well they're all they're all
unfortunately Jordan they're all uh
dancing to the same tune uh on all sides
of this debate and this why I said
essentially it comes down to uh this uh
subject object problem or dilemma
because
um you've got valid critiques on both
sides I'm not too offended by the
communist critique of capitalism and I'm
not too offended by the capitalist
critique of Communism my problem is when
the Communists say we've got the
solution and you're going to have to
follow it or when unchecked corporatism
says everything's for sale everything's
a product and you and you shouldn't
regulate um and you know to the extent
where these days as you know Jordan if
you've been following even traffic
children are for sale so I think the I
think the problem is that there is
legitimate critique on both sides of the
other but because there's a subject
object problem the solution each side is
proposing is other rising of uh the
people that they are they see as their
adversaries and that's the classic
dilemma let's put it uh whether it's a
political Compass you're going to use or
the political horseshoe um even the
symbolism of the Cross is this you've
got the left and the right and the up
and the down but that makes the whole
we've got to have a way uh to look at
the World by first looking ourselves in
a holistic way so if we can step back
from subject object and the problem
really began with the I think with the
Advent of writing
um where this shift in Psychology began
occurring the Kali Yuga period uh in
India for example
I am a an Arabic linguist I come uh with
a particular love in my heart for the
oral tradition of the classical Arabic
language
which is the closest language surviving
today that has a continuous Heritage
because Hebrew from the Aramaic family
of languages are had to be revived but
the closest living
language to uh yeshua's Aramaic is
quranic Arabic and perhaps Amharic as
well you could argue as well uh uh there
but I think that this is why I reflect
on this subject object issue a lot
because that was a the Bedouin culture
was a very oral tradition and when you
put what happens is when you put words
into letters on a page
uh uh I think you engage then in the
kind of inversion that's that leads to
the subject object otherization because
those words that we I say are spells
those words that we use
um they had a uh a context in which they
were uh allocated to the thing they were
used to describe or the verb the action
that was said to be done they had that
context there the minute we put them
down on paper and then memorize them and
allow the analytical mind to process
their meanings whether we like it or not
it's impossible to ever ReDiscover the
experience that was there in the oral
tradition for how the words were used in
their proper context
um now there's loads of examples for
this but I'll give you one example
in Arabic often the word haram is
translated to mean prohibited
nothing could be further from the truth
and and by the way I as you would know
again from my own history I include
Muslim common everyday Muslim
translations of the word you know I'm
not here to say this is a orientalist
problem
um but the because translations here and
the way I'm using them is psychological
translations not the uh which particular
language you choose to uh to to to
um uh translate this into it could even
be modern usage of Arabic by Arabs but
psychologically they're translating it
wrong it doesn't mean prohibited Haram
actually means sacred if you go to
Makkah and you see the Black House of
Allah there that's called Masjid
al-haram the sacred house it's the same
word
haram right why I raise that example is
because what is the so-called prohibited
if you shift into an oral tradition it
there was nothing prohibited in that
sense what was prohibited about it was
the context around which it occurred
so sex outside of a sacred partnership
and I use that word again on purpose and
not the word just to drive home the
point I'm trying to make yeah yeah sex
outside of a sacred partnership is the
very same act but in one context it's
sacred I.E harama sacred in the other
context is Haram
profane and that's why the sacred and
the profane are simply the silver and
dark side of a mirror
the meaning of the word changes only
because of its context and again
marriage to continue that example why I
said sacred partnership and not the word
marriage is because the word in Arabic
is zoja
for your life partner your sacred
partner zelja means pair it doesn't mean
wife and it doesn't mean subservient it
means prayer in Arabic yeah you're
pairing so what we have is uh
which again commonly Mis translated as
the contract of marriage means
the tying of a pair Ox comes from the
word not
now that word not yeah which today is
again mistranslated to mean contract
which takes all the spirit and love out
of that yeah which is why you have these
prenuptial agreements as well Arc
actually means Thai to tie a knot so the
actors the tying of a pair they don't
have to be married they have to be in a
sacred relationship that not that you
you're tying there happens to be the
word for again commonly misranslated to
Doctrine Akida is from the same root
there which means again to have a not
with Allah so you see how the context
around those words are fundamentally
different we've lost that context
because we've lost that oral tradition
which is why you and I agree that
traditionalism can go a long way to
restoring and healing those wounds that
the overly analytical mind uh has has
inflicted upon itself uh by what we lost
when we lost the oral tradition why is
all of that relevant because and forgive
me for the for the long anecdote there
linguistic anecdote or hermeneutic
anecdote why why all of that in my view
is relevant is because it comes back to
the problem with we're speaking of
once we take words out of their context
and put them on paper and I'm no Luddite
so I'm not saying the written word
should never have been invented
um the prophet Muhammad May uh blessings
be upon Him didn't write the Quran down
it was never written down during his
lifetime it was actually collected on
stones and leaves and it was the third
caliph othman who collected it in one
book which is why today it's called
Mustafa Usman the one that you know and
that everyone sees as the Quran it's
called man that was only brought about
and collected during the third caliph
during the caliphate of or the
successorship again a word very
mistranslated uh Khalif means successor
too our line is messenger that's all it
means in the temporal sense because no
one can succeed him in the prophethood
so that successor Abu Bakr and then
after him armor they did not collate the
Quran for the very same reason instead
it was memorized in the hearts because
people didn't want to lose the context
of the words around them that tradition
by the way of memorizing as you know
carries on till today I've memorized
half of it myself
um though I'm a bit Rusty but um it was
the third caddy for that then put that
so I'm not against putting things down
in writing what I'm saying is we've got
to be cognizant of what we lose when we
do that so that we can try and maintain
the connection that we lose when we do
that and it's that connection or the
knot that I'm saying has been lost today
and you with your uh advocacy for a a a
deeper appreciation of traditional
mythologies and wisdom I think hopefully
would understand when I say that
connection we've lost so if we can
strengthen that connection pre-subject
object
recognize that we're all a point on a
sphere in other words we're all part of
an indivisible whole then the other ring
is declined of course it's always a
struggle because that connection can be
weak sometimes but that's why you engage
in spiritual practice to strengthen it
and whatever way that is personally my
teacher is Sheikh Ali Al qadri I'm of
the Sufi way yeah but the Sufi Way by
definition would say that listen I'm not
going to say to you you have to follow
me right this is you this is like the
Sharia it means the path to water in the
desert you go to water for life and then
you carry on traveling that's all Sharia
means by the way the path to water so if
we can understand what we've lost when
when we put words down in writing is we
lost the relational aspect
uh uh of the technology writing was
technology yeah why all of that is
relevant I believe is today as I
mentioned when my conversation a year
ago with Joe uh Rogan
um today the version of writing writing
today is Big Tech is social media it's
taking us to that next stage of
Separation in the name of togetherness
in the in the name of community is
actually pulling us apart and as you see
with your own concerns on uh anonymity
on Twitter it's psychologically allowing
people to abuse others and speak to them
in another Rising tone which is
precisely what your concern was with
Anonymous uh people on Twitter I don't
think by the way the solution is
anonymity but that's another topic you
know yeah well there's something there
that that you're pointing to I'm going
to go in a couple of directions on this
you're pointing to the dangers of
um
what would you say it's it's a
formalized abstraction I mean as we
build conceptual systems that are
linguistic they get more and more
distant from the embodied experience
that's that contextualized embodied
experience that you were referring to
and they lose their connection with with
what's most real
and we could Define what's most real as
the domain of the Sacred I want to give
you an analogy this is something
extraordinarily interesting now she had
a couple of months ago there was a paper
published in the journal Nature about
the nature of genetic mutation
okay so it's been thought for a long
time that genetic mutations are
essentially random
and the reason for that is that
the molecular structure the atomic
structure of a given strand of DNA can
be detrimentally affected by all sorts
of environmental assaults including
radiation Cosmic radiation norc pieces
of the genetic code out and that
produces a mutation there's other ways
that can happen and then those mutations
are part of what produces natural
variation and natural selection draws on
that natural variation to further
Evolution but the idea was that the
mutations were random and they have to
be in some sense because cosmic rays
don't care what part of the DNA chain
they affect but it's been recently
discovered that although the mutations
themselves may be random
the repair process isn't
and so DNA when it replicates it error
corrects
and if there are parts of the DNA strand
that are have been damaged and are no
longer viable they will be corrected but
there's a hierarchy of Correction
and so the more fundamental a DNA code
is to the basic necessary morphology of
the organism the higher the probability
that the error correction will be 100
percent
and so what happens is that Evolution
Tinkers on the fringes and not at the
core
and the core in in this hierarchy of DNA
importance is is analogous to the sacred
so imagine in a conceptual structure
there are some presuppositions that are
that many other presuppositions depend
upon they're fundamental
and those fundamental presuppositions
are sacred and the reason it's forbidden
to mess with them is it's like touching
the Ark of the Covenant is if you if you
touch what's properly sacred with a
profane hand you will be struck dead
and that's the truth now the question is
what's validly sacred now the
enlightenment types would say
everything's equally up for grabs but
they don't even abide by that principle
in their own investigations because for
example Someone Like Richard Dawkins
holds it as holy the notion that the
truth will set you free and that the
cosmos has a logos whose investigation
will Enlighten and and further our
struggle forward and those are sacred
religious presuppositions that underlie
the practice of science just like they
underlie the practice of any religious
tradition there is a hierarchy of
presumption and the presumptions at the
deepest level are the sacred
presumptions now you talked about
marriage and the ability of a sacred
bond to render sex
sacred instead of profane and I think
that is one of the Sacred realizations
of mankind that the sexual act has to be
Sanctified has to be placed in a domain
of fundamental relationship before it
can act as anything other than a
destructive impulsive hedonistic force
and I think that that's as true as
anything is true now part of what's
ripping us apart on the international
landscape and psychologically at the
moment is that it's very difficult for
us number one to agree that there are
such things as sacred propositions and
second to agree on what those are and
this is part of what's also making it
difficult for the Islamic Christian and
Jewish faiths to come together so one
example of that for example would be
well would be continued debate about the
centrality of the figure of Christ and
so
perhaps we can delve into that to some
degree but I'd love that that elucidates
the landscape that we're dealing with in
a little bit may I say detail may I say
on your first challenge what is
uh sorry is there a sacred as opposed to
what is it I think that there is a way a
A Gentle Way Forward on that one uh and
actually that would help even if we
could like like the other point about
language I was trying to make that if we
can at least agree that our language
shouldn't be exclusionary we at least
have a way to uh try and have a
conversation I think likewise uh uh if
we can at least agree that there that
there should be that there is a sacred
then the next level challenge is what is
that sacred and I think there is a way
forward here because back to the um
back to the relationship between words
and their context and why I believe when
you put words down again I'm not allowed
right and again so in today's context
why this is relevant again just for
everyone and I know you're following me
Jordan but why this is relevant for
everyone is the equivalent of inventing
writing today is you know social media
big Tech and it's a new invention that's
forcing us to cognitively evolve in a
certain way and that's what we're seeing
all these challenges it's like the 30
Years War I made this point with Rogan a
year ago so I think there is a way
forward to say that there should be a
sacred and why that is is back to the
invention of writing to serve as the
case study for or as a symbol for
today's big Tech uh and its impact on us
and and it's and it's uh consequences
we're having to live with when they put
writing down
what it did is it made us believe our
future is ahead of us and our past is
behind us
when in truth our future is behind us
and our past is ahead of us and I need
to unpack that
when you write history down in a book
you're you're going in chronology in
chronological order because that's the
inherent capabilities that we have and
how we write and where whether in Arabic
from right to left in Hebrew from right
to left in Aramaic family languages or
from left to right in English
um
you're writing in a certain timeline
it's his story right it's the story of
the author and they cannot but either
right from their perspective or from the
perspective of the king they serve or
from the or from their perspective
being a culmination of the efforts to
gather the people's perspectives but it
will still always be their perspective
on the people's perspective of what
happened in history
so we cannot but help try and write in a
chronological order now what that leads
to is another illusion that our past is
behind us and our future is ahead of us
the written word psychologically does
that to us I believe
the truth is why is our past ahead of us
and our future behind us because
actually
if you look at it if you look at it from
the oral tradition if you look at it
from the Aramaic family of languages
better wins people that lived for that
connection they were all about survival
of their genes you brought up DNA
it was about survival their family if
they lost a child in that context
I mean that means more than losing a
child today if you get my drift because
it meant cutting off of their entire
ability to exist that child could well
have been the one that continued the
future of that tribe
your child is Therefore your future
even though it comes after you which is
what I meant by the past is ahead of us
your your child is your future the
things you leave behind are the future
the things you've done
you know it it doesn't matter what
matters is if you build it for your
future which is a thing you left behind
are your children if we understand it
like that and that comes from the
Bedouin Collective kind of and when I
say Collective I don't mean in a
communist Soviet sense I hope you
understand I mean in the every every
point on a sphere is the center of the
sphere and yet it's still a point yeah
when you understand it in that context
you understand that sacred if it were to
mean anything at all would be to be
doing actions as an individual and as a
community that don't harm that child
what we've come to today because of the
way in which psychologically we have
inverted
everything's up for sale again back to
subject object the minute we separate
from that connection
the minute we cause that separation
which in metaphysical terms would be or
let's call them in let's say you know in
uh in Sufi terms that's without as
opposed to with yeah so the minute we
are or that there is no Idol rather than
illallah except the one indivisible
whole of infinite love Infinite Power 99
Names whichever attribute we choose
they're all serving the same purpose the
minute we cause that disassociative
state The psychosis the separation from
that Source we are in subject object
when you're in subject object everything
is for sale
when everything's for sale there is no
reason not to include children and
that's where we find ourselves today now
whether it's the trafficking I raised
earlier which by the way is not just
um I mean it's everywhere you know the
the reason I say is not just because
it's also in Kiev the war that we are so
yeah arrogantly supporting you know so
so the problem is it's not just the
trafficking as you know Jordan with the
um
with the uh this decision the underage
pre-pubescent children have the right to
consent to their genital mutilation
without parental involvement at all
again is a profane stance to take
it's Unforgivable
yeah and but that demonstrates the
subject object problem we have
commodified everything
and oh that can only that's only
possible because of separation and I've
come to these conclusions Jordan not
that I don't don't get me wrong this is
the evolution of my own thinking on this
because uh it would began with the wegar
genocide I was pre-cancellation on LBC
the we got situation shocked me to my
core and I saw a coming technocracy and
how it can enslave an entire people and
then when covid hit I had already
because I don't know if you have
followed any of it and forgive me again
this is not to boast in any way but I
did
um a four-day hunger strike uh for the
week all Muslims you know complaining of
the Chinese Communist party's treatment
of their of and disrespect of the
Heritage they could have been Tibetan uh
Buddhists they could have been Chinese
Christians
um
and in many campaigns I've been involved
in they have been for every not just
Muslims right that's why I'm making that
point
um but it shocked me to my core because
I saw a coming technocracy in what's
possible with the uh the end result of
the direction of travel that certain
people through their dialectical
materialism would like to take us to and
that's what I call the technocratic
Tyranny yeah so then when covered by the
time covid came
I had already been shocked to a point
where I left my work I was on a live
show and I went on a four-day silent
hunger strike risking being canceled at
that point but thankfully uh that isn't
what got me canceled but by the time
covid came I was already primed and my
own uh my own um experience had
experiences had started on a New Journey
post uh not just from post prison but
post even everything I've done in the
last 10 years that Evolution had to
carry on because I had to look at myself
and and see what things have I
participated in
in my own last 10 years of uh of
campaigning that could have perhaps
helped that techno techno technocratic
train along its tracks uh uh whether
unwittingly or not and I realized yeah
for example I've said things like
um you know these nations are
on Democratic uh they don't have
democracy inherent to their cultural
Traditions which is probably true yeah
and I say these in referring Any
non-democratic Nation not singling
anyone out here
probably true that they didn't have but
then I realized that during covid if the
very people that were
peddling this myth that we are in charge
of our own destiny those very people
locked at roughly 70 percent of the
world into their homes until they
consented to a forced injection
those very same people could turn off
your money supply
just because you are protesting out on
the streets of Ottawa and I really we've
noticed without we've noticed that yeah
indeed they can do it so I realized
Canadians think that's a good idea by
the way uh crazy right but I realized I
had been unwittingly participating in
the problem it's why I'm explaining it
in this way to say I've also been uh on
a journey in that way to realize that I
had been participating in a problem
because my belief up until that point
was that there were certain countries in
the world that were under tyranny and
that others that were free and the truth
is there are certain countries in the
world that are under the illusion of
freedom and the rest of the world is
under tyranny and the illusion of
freedom is still okay comfortable but
you better bet that when they want to
turn off your food supply your money
your ability to trade and buy and sell
uh agenda 2030 Jordan have a look at it
zero meat consumption consumption I know
no cars yeah I know I know so I realized
that I had but I had become an unwitting
tool for advocating for certain
civilizational values that I still hold
dear to and by the way I have sacrificed
for and the people I thought that were
my allies in advocating for those values
are actually my enemy but enemy in a I
don't mean in a warlike sense I mean
intellectually you know I I my adversary
to put to be polite about the situation
they don't subscribe to these values
whatsoever
and so then I I realized what what was
wrong in me
to be unable to see that and I realized
that I had also Fallen prey to this
problem I was describing one half of the
dualism I referred to earlier I was in
the ying and not the Yang or the Yang
not the ying and not realizing if you
zoom out there there's an entire atom
and if we understand that we cannot
approach it with love and uh and you
mentioned you wanted to talk about
Yeshua uh but this is the same I want to
comment on your your circle on your
sphere of metaphor okay so I read a I
read a very interesting
description of God once and this is
derived from Jewish thought and I
believe I encountered this when I was
reading yog so the proposition is God is
a circle whose circumference is nowhere
and whose Center is everywhere yeah and
that's allied with this idea that each
person is of divine worth and made in
the image of God
it's the same idea right is that each of
us is a center
and that's a very strange thing because
we tend to think of things as having a
single Center but whatever the world is
is complex enough so that it has a
multiplicity of centers and I do believe
that to be the case and I do believe
that each of us is For Better or Worse
at that Center I also think that Center
by the way is symbolized by the cross
because the cross is the center and the
point of maximal suffering so that's
part of what that symbol means
psychologically and so now you say that
things go astray when we forget that
right you're using the metaphor of this
fear and I think that's right things go
astray when we lose the notion that each
human being is a locus of divinity in
the most fundamental sense and that it's
the moral responsibility of each person
to make that Divinity manifest to the
degree that they're possible and that
the world is a much lesser place when
people don't do that and it's incumbent
on you to take yourself apart to see
where you're failing to do that long
before you worry about whether someone
else is failing to do that yeah which
doesn't mean that you should you know
lay yourself open to idiot victimization
on the Tyranny front but it does mean
that you shouldn't put the cart before
the horse and it is very easy to see the
problem as out there in the world which
it also is instead of it being some
something that has to be contended with
within the confines of your own heart
and it does start and this also ties
back to our discussion about what
constitutes what's sacred so in the
in the tradition emergency did you agree
with my basic proposition on that on
that note there on the what there is a
sacred
yes absolutely and that's absolutely
well in that that idea that that
sacrality is associated with the notion
of diverse centers is metaphorically and
symbolically and historically
appropriate and then you might ask well
what does it mean to be such a center
and I would say and you've been
stressing the idea of love for example
in this conversation and so here's a
here's a couple of definitions of love
all right so one would be the the
commitment to the
the commitment to the proposition that
it would be better if everything
flourished so that's the notion of life
more abundant and that's the anti the
opposite of an antenatalist approach so
the the the
um
the sacred approach that insists upon
the centrality of each individual is
predicated on the idea that existence
itself is fundamentally good
if existence is operating according to
the principles of love and according to
the principles of Truth so you see in
the Genesis story for example God uses
the Divine word to create order out of
chaos and the Divine word is honest but
also devoted towards love and the idea
is that words spoken in that Spirit
bring about the order that is good and
transmute the cosmos as a consequence
and that each of us is doing that
wittingly or unwittingly worse or better
with every word we speak and that's
partly why the idea of the logos which
is the Divine word is so Central
particularly to Christian thought but
obviously also to Islamic and Jewish
thought because there's a tremendous
stress laid on the sacrality of the word
but this is why it's because the word
spoken properly produces a cosmos that's
habitable that's habitable and good and
that's the fundamental sacred principle
and I think it's I think it's just true
it's it's true metaphorically
traditionally it's true scientifically
it's true at every possible level of
analysis and then it's incumbent on
people to act in accordance with that
and it's incumbent on our political and
economic organizations to organize
themselves in what would you say in a
manner that's commensurate with that
individual sacrality that that's also
the source of our idea of individual
right it's not State it's not State
granted which is something insisted upon
by Enlightenment rationalists precisely
and and if I may if we arrive at that
and what you've just echoed is also IBN
Arabi so in the uh in the Islamic
mystical tradition IBN arabi's ideas of
uh uh or the Oneness of being
um is a similar approach to this and if
we if we can tap into that one thing we
understand is again I agree with you is
that everyone if everyone is sacred
what we've got a problem with is is when
we invent technology
we are uh uh engaging in that process of
the separation and every time a
civilizational uh steering uh
intervention technological intervention
is is created it takes us further along
that path of Separation because we are
appropriating the divine
in the thing we make it's a reflection
of it if it's only ever you know what
the TV is I looked at my eye and thought
how do I copy it yeah uh so whenever we
do that
um
uh make a record of The Human Experience
we're separating now that doesn't mean
again that we're luddites but if we
acknowledge this if we're cognizant of
this Behavior then we understand that
not only must we constantly nourish that
connection to the source so that it
guides that technological uh invention
as it comes about and I could apply the
same the written word what can be said
about the written word I did say on
Rogan about the printing press and I
believe again what I did say that we're
in that moment again now with the Advent
of
um uh the big Tech
that's the Tower of Babel problem so
what happens immediately after the flood
in the Genesis narrative is the
emergence of the Tower of Babel as a
let's call it you can think about it as
a as an antidote to the flood too much
chaos what'll we do well we'll build a a
tower of technological artifacts
that stretches to the sky
and then we won't need God
right and so it isn't the problem the
tower isn't the problem it's the
presumption of the tower Builders and
the tower inhabitants that the tower now
supplants the Transcendent that's the
problem let's say of the Communist
Doctrine which is fundamentally
materialistic it's like and that's why
it becomes totalitarian that's its
attempt to supplant what's Transcendent
and the consequence of that so
interestingly in the Tower of Babel
story is that the presumptuous
technocrats and bureaucrats and perhaps
scientists and technologists build the
Tower of Babel as an alternative to the
proper Divine uh uh what would you call
it uh lyanna Between Heaven and Earth
and then it takes on this nightmarish
quality and the end consequence of that
is that no one can speak to each other
anymore is that the most fundamental
elements of communication become
fragmented to the point where no
communication is possible because
everything truly sacred that with ground
communication has now been dispensed
with and then we're in the situation
where we ask well what is a woman for
example so you know exactly what you've
just said there is exactly what I've
been trying to say as well so we're on
the same page now on all of this and so
extending that technology
if we're not constantly nourishing that
connection to the source in other words
the width rather than the without yeah
so uh if we're not constantly aware of
this danger and it happened with the
printing press it happened with the
written word it's now happening we're in
the moment I believe where big Tech is
doing that to us it's creating that
Tower of Babel's division separation in
the name of unity in the name of unity
the uh we're encouraging homogenization
with absurdly no Foundation upon which
we we can ever agree upon for consensus
uh so right it's a very strange
situation we're finding ourselves in
that if if we understand what that does
we understand that institutions and
systems have inherent within them the
tendency to create and further that
separation and disconnect or psychosis
or yeah or disassociate associative
experience institutions and systems do
that by definition which is why the
worst example of it is the communist
state uh but but if we understand that
then we understand another thing another
great Insight I believe and that is that
the void that is created by the
invention of this Tech which leads to
becoming Incorporated in systems and
institutions the void that is created uh
between the dot on the sphere and the
sphere itself in other words in
recognizing that indivisible hole while
also recognizing that we're each a point
yeah we're a wavelength we're a particle
so that gap between being a wavelength
and a particle being a DOT on the sphere
and being the sphere itself this the
institutions are the thing that are
widening that Gap systems are I call it
the machine
this is why Yeshua is important because
Yeshua comes with love and one thing
again that we have in common by the way
is it's the understanding of the abiding
importance of Yeshua and yeshua's return
why because symbolically what does that
mean is
the void and by weed by we mean Muslims
and Christians yes yes yes okay here I'm
talking to you in the in the in the
singular here the we here's yeah but
yeah but metaphorically of course what
it means for the broader conversation is
that void that is created there when we
have systems adopting new tech and the
separation that creates between the
human and the Machine
that void has to be filled with love
it's the only way we can go forward and
this is the the sacred version of it as
opposed to the profane version of it but
if we take out that love if we take out
the sacred connection you will end up
with the profane you will end up with
this technocratic activity where in it
recently coming yeah yeah it's already
above us it's over us and the uh uh the
the sense for human dignity respect for
the individual's choices the the
sacredness of the individual is being
erased
yeah and that's what the covid Mandate
period demonstrated is what the
15-minute cities are demonstrating
Oxford in in the United Kingdom the
famous Oxford city has already passed
this the only to my knowledge the only
city in the world that actually proposed
it as a council and then decided to
backtrack and then promise they would
never enforce it was ironically the uh
my The Townhouse City now it's a town
then the town I was born in south end on
sea in Essex uh which recently announced
it would permanently no longer consider
adopting this 15-minute City oh God
other than that yep other than the city
of South End in Essex
all other cities are adopting this and
so we're seeing uh the uh encroachment
of this technocratic tyranny because I
believe we have this separation is going
to become exacerbated unless we remember
our connection to the source and in that
vein it's again why I believe that other
Rising language in this moment we're in
is so we have to be so careful about it
because it's ready to blow Jordan yeah
across the world right you look at Modi
in India you look at Netanyahu and
Israel you look at the covered mandates
in the west you look at Hamas you look
at the whole world is ready to blow the
polarization has got to Iran which you
and I again are with our posts online uh
you know we we interacted on the topic
of Iran the whole world is the tectonic
plates have shifted to a point where
some shocks are coming our way and uh
we're out of Crossroads and and the only
way we're going to get through this in a
way I believe ultimately we will get
through it by the way but I I cannot but
Advocate uh or do perform the role that
I believe I'm here for which is to
advocate that we get through this in a
uh in a sacred way in a way that is not
profane in a way that uh protects the
sanctity of the human being but I but we
we uh all of us who believe in that need
allies in that task because we're in a I
believe we're at a Crossroads it's a
very very sensitive moment we're in and
I don't believe most of our colleagues
appreciate the moment we're in most of
them as the blues singers from the
American South know well you meet the
devil at the crossroads so precisely and
and you know this French of ours that we
have in common that I'm you know I
believe have failed they've missed this
completely
well you know we we keep talking all of
us in the hopes that we get smarter as
we do so and we'll hope we manage that
and maybe we manage that together to
some degree today I'm we're out of time
on the YouTube front here and that's a
pretty good place to end even though
obviously we could keep talking
endlessly which is pretty much what both
you and I do and so I hope we get a
chance to pick this up again in the not
ridiculously distant future I'm coming
to the UK in April maybe we could meet
then
um I've also started an Enterprise
called The Alliance for responsible
citizenship that's an attempt to provide
something like an alternative to this
Tower of Babel horror that seems to be
descending upon us and in any case for
everyone who's watching and listening on
the YouTube platform and its Associated
channels thank you very much for your
time and attention and to the Daily wear
Plus for facilitating this conversation
and setting it up technically that's
much appreciated to the film crew here
in in Seattle thanks for your time and
effort
everyone I'm going to continue talking
to Majid for another half an hour on the
daily wire plus platform and we'll do
something more autobiographical uh
delving into
Majid's history and the manner in which
his interests and problems have made
themselves manifest in his life and so
if you're interested in that head over
to the Daily wire plus side of things
and thank you very much Majid it was
very good talking to you and I think we
got some distance today so hooray for
that
thank you and you're always welcome uh
to London anytime you come and and Tammy
as well we've met obviously on many an
occasion I'm yet to meet Michaela but
you're always welcome and uh our door is
always open for you and uh you're also
always welcome to appear on any other
platforms we have
um at any time of your choosing and
comfort whenever you are uh ready or not
it's up to you but our door remains open
for you so thank you very much Jordan
great man appreciate the invitation all
right well thank you all very much and
uh ciao imagine
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com